smeared
it's like a disaster the city is almost
ruined in the district where i'm living
it's
like no houses which were not bombed
yesterday there was
they probably the hardest woman and like
you know the lights
and the
sound is so scary and the whole building
is
shaking
and iron my children we were sitting
like half of night
and the doorway because it's like the
safest place
and i decided that it's enough
we walked
on foot and
actually there was a man who helped our
family and drive drove us here
and he told his family
were killed
and he is helping refugees so i can't
say that i'm a refugee actually i'm
quite a prosperous woman with a fled but
now it's absolutely not important what
is important is that my children are
here
well honestly it's really terrible but
all in all we must
support each other
and don't give up and all in all
everything will be all right
my feeling is that
i'm afraid about tomorrow i'm defending
about now what i heard about tomorrow
what we have in ukraine next what's the
next day
what's our future here we have here our
family we have here our business we have
here all our life is built here i'm
living seven years in ukraine i have
built a good life here and now i don't
know what's my future what's tomorrow
what's going to happen
it's really
we are lost we don't know what we are
doing